[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ja wir haben schon
wieder getan ein neues xxl video diesmal
ein kinder regel in xxl ich meine kinder
regel geht doch echt immer oder und wir
schauen uns diese kinder region an und
biss besondere merkmal sind ja diese
fünf hügel fünf hügel und diese fiel
aussparungen und darum kümmern wir uns
jetzt auch als allererstes denn was er
dafür benötigt ist zum einen eine
kastenform die hatte denk ich mal wieder
zu hause und wir sind auch genommen die
sind eigentlich von der größe her immer
gleich und pappe und mit dieser karte
zeige ich euch jetzt wie hier diese
aussparungen diese kleinen vögel
hinkriegt so wir benötigen insgesamt
vier von diesen teilen drei habe ich
schon vorbereitet den vierten machen
jetzt gemeinsam und zwar sind das ganze
mal kartons die habe ich mir zurecht
geschnitten
ich schreibe euch die maße auf jeden
fall unten in die infobox hier dass es
unser boden sozusagen das bleibt gerade
und das hier müssen wir dann einfach so
knicken das geht ja ganz gleich mit den
händen so dass es dann oval ist so und
jetzt kleben wir das ganz einfach
zusammen habe ich schon meint ihr
verband
[Musik]
so sieht die form nun aus und das ganze
müssen wir jetzt noch stoppen damit es
ein bisschen stabiler ist ich nehme mir
ganz einfach küchenrolle knickt das
einmal und dann rolle ich das einmal auf
so und jetzt stopfen wir das ganz
einfach da rein und die lange das was
rauskommt sag ich mal das schneiden wird
ganz einfach so damit das nicht in
berührung mit unserer milch creme kommen
brauchen wir jetzt noch frischhaltefolie
und wickeln das ganz einfach ein
[Musik]
so dienten müssen wir jetzt auch
abschneiden weil die jetzt zu lang sind
nicht ganz kurz schneiden immer so ich
hab doch froh dass ich so einfach am
besten ist und dann das einfach hier
unten drunter klemmen und auch mit
dieser band fixieren gleichen mit der
anderen seite das war es schon
jetzt haben wir uns die vier teile
vorbereitet und weiter geht's mit der
kastenform so das funktioniert am
allerbesten wenn ihr die vorher nass
macht einfach mit leitungswasser und
dann geben wir doch frischhaltefolie
rein damit wir das ganze später auch
richtig schön anheben können
so weiter geht es jetzt mit unseren
trainern mit unserem rücken trainern ich
weiß wie es denn so auch im fall tun wir
die jetzt mit der flachen seite nach
unten einmal in gleichmäßigen abständen
rein
[Musik]
so vorbereitet ist die form jetzt können
wir starten mit der leckere milch creme
ich sehe schon richtig vor meinem
geistigen auge wie dieses xxl
kinderriegel aussehen wird ich bin
richtig gespannt jetzt zeige ich euch
zuallererst die zutaten für die milch
geben für die legendäre milch cremen
benötigen wir weiße kuvertüre außerdem
gezuckerte kondensmilch etwas kokosfett
und nochmal für den extra milchigen
geschmack ein wenig milch pulver zum
reinbeißen
naja ich hab wasser in einem topf
aufkochen lassen und jetzt machen wir
das ganze über einem wasserbad deswegen
habe ich auch die weiße kuvertüre extra
in eine größere schiffe gegeben und
jetzt kommen hierzu noch palmen und die
gezuckerte kondensmilch und jetzt lassen
wir das ganz einfach schmelzen und
anschließend geben wir noch das
milchpulver mit hinzu
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt die masse die ist mega
dickflüssig und jetzt geben wir unseren
milchpulver rein
es gibt es in größeren supermärkten wer
das nicht findet kann einfach die
gleiche menge durch palm ihn ersetzen
[Musik]
so die leckere milch masse ist fertig
und wir müssen die auch sofort weiter
verwenden nicht dass wir uns noch kalt
jetzt aber ich träume jetzt ganz schnell
den herzberg und zeigt euch dann sehe
ich die form gefüllt
jetzt fühlen wir die masse bahrain und
oh mein gott leute ich hab schon
probiert das schmeckt original die diese
füllung von der kinderschokolade jetzt
können wir das einmal vorsichtig hier
rein
[Musik]
so und jetzt streichen wir die
oberfläche schön glatt
[Musik]
also das könnt ihr übrigens auch mit dem
löffel rücken machen oder mit einem teig
schaber also falls sie keine winkel
palette da hat es gar kein problem
[Musik]
so jetzt müssen wir alle stark bleiben
denn das ganze muss drei bis vier
stunden auskühlen im kühlschrank also
nicht in der gewinn- gefrierfach auf
jeden fall im kühlschrank und dann sehen
uns ganz bald wieder so da bin ich
wieder da und der xxl kinder regel ist
richtig schön fest geworden jetzt lassen
wir das allerdings noch in der form und
geben da geschmolzener kuvertüre rein
und zwar damit wir den boden schon mal
haben und später drehen wir das ganze
machen die restliche kuvertüre drauf
[Musik]
so jetzt kommt das ganze wieder in den
kühlschrank aber keine sorge nicht so
lang so um die 20 minuten bis das fest
geworden ist und dann geht's schon an
den finalen letzten schritt also wir
kommen der sache doch schon jetzt ist
die schokolade fest geworden mit können
wir das endlich aus der form rausnehmen
doch einmal die von ihr vollständig
entfernen
so und jetzt müssen wir nur noch hier
oben etwas begradigen sei aber schon die
form sieht richtig gut aus
[Musik]
so jetzt wird es ganz so einmal
umgedreht und dann können wir die pappe
entfernt
[Musik]
also es ist ganz normal dass wir da ein
bisschen nachhelfen müssen die
schokolade ist ja darunter geflossen das
ist kein problem aber ich finde die form
sie schon mal richtig richtig gut aus
[Musik]
würde kartons sind jetzt alle raus ich
finde das sieht schon richtig nach einem
xxl kinder regel aus aber wer es um so
auch die feinheiten achtet der kann
jetzt noch hier diese reststücke nehmen
die an den karton haften geblieben sind
und das verhält sich so ein bisschen die
modelle schokolade
ihr könnt man zum beispiel wenn
irgendwas nicht richtig gerade ist
einfach hier rein tun mit den händen
schön glatt streichen und dann sieht
alles super aus so jetzt kommt aber
wirklich der finale aller allerletzte
schritt und zwar habe ich hier schon
kuvertüre geschmolzen und damit die
nicht so knackig ist wenn man das eine
man schneidet gebe ich dann noch ein
bisschen kokosfett rein
[Musik]
so perfekt und jetzt habe ich mich hier
auch schon etwas vorbereitet und zwar
hier so eine kleine station wo ich die
den kinder regel drauf tun kann und dann
ließen wir die schokolade darüber am
besten sind wir da irgendwelche gräser
oder tasten dann gehen wir erstmal unser
kinder regel drauf und dann wird das
ganze mit der schokolade über kaufen ich
freu mich schon
[Musik]
doch das was jetzt hier an überschuss in
den reden ist die könnt ihr mit so einem
löffel mit so einem kleinen löffel
rücken einfach wegschieben
[Musik]
so jetzt müssen wir nur noch hier unten
das trotz der alles ein bisschen runter
und dann könnt ihr mit messer hier so
lang fahren und den überschuss einmal
wegnehmen
[Musik]
falls nämlich das ganz vorsichtig runter
und wo das wieder zurück auf meinem bett
um es dann im kühlschrank zu geben weil
das muss ja noch fest wenn die kubatur
und dann endlich endlich kann ich da
rein weißen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bevor wir aufnehmen von anfang
aufzunehmen
also probieren
seit zwei tagen ist dieses linke fertig
und wir dürfen es einfach mal
ausprobieren
wer noch fotos gemacht habe und impact
damit waren und die haben uns doch an
den blutig
ich habe jetzt aber ich muss sagen ich
hab richtig sympathien gewonnen hierfür
ist mir richtig ans herz gewachsen
so danke das problem
oder willst du nein ich darf ich hab ich
nichts gemacht bevor wir anfangen
entschieden ich mal kurz um die sagt was
wir haben seit als erstes machen wir
schnick schnack schnuck seit jahren
immer schon so vorgefunden wie kann man
einfach ohne ohne nachzudenken was immer
die zähne und ich habe immer den boden
weil ich weiß es ehrlich ich hab schon
mal durch das heftig für das schmeckt so
lecker dass mit so heftig wie kinder
ringe das schmeckt einfach original nach
dieser regel original jetzt das micro
rät ruhig ein bisschen schröer bisschen
findest du aber ich finde man konnte
jetzt sehr gut rein weil ich schneide
jetzt mal meinen teil ab damit auch
später die anderen puppen oder morgen
wir haben sich 21 34 das geht mir ja ich
weiß dass hier noch zu ende
ich will nicht wissen wie viel wir haben
gar nicht geboren
sommer schnell noch nie so schnell wie
wegen jetzt noch und also obwohl sie ab
gewissen haben soll
wir sehen jetzt nur alle die mal bittet
mehreren du bist so ein kinder regel
eigentlich steht auf der verpackung aber
kommen der vollständigkeit halber 121
gramm und unser kinder regel wird das
wir schon abgebissen haben aber macht ja
nicht nur die teile jetzt so drauf und
dann runde einfach mal auf 1100 gramm
also über ein kilo haben wir geschafft
also dieser regel passt einfach mal ganz
kann gerechnet 53 mal in unseren xxl wgl
[Musik]
das ist doch essen wächst
also die genauen mengenangaben stehen
wie immer unten in der infobox geht
einkaufen macht es nach und ich bin
gespannt was ihr zu sagen habt schickt
mir gerne wieder mal eure fotos mit dem
hashtag s kitchen über instagram da
freue ich mich immer sehr darauf vor
allem finde ich es richtig cool dass ihr
die xxl erzeugte von mir auch so fleißig
nach macht ihr könnt euch meine anderen
xxl rezepte auch gern anschauen die
verlinkte ich euch auch noch mal hier
uns in der infobox und dann sage ich bis
zum nächsten mal auf die sketche
[Musik]